now that the years horror releases are
all but set in stone film studios are
looking ahead to draw audiences to
theaters with a brand new round of
exciting trailers what treats did
September deliver here's a roundup of
all the best trailers from September
2018 first man Apollo 11 may have put a
man on the moon but first man is putting
the humanity in the moon landing the
latest trailer for universals dramatic
biopic about Neil Armstrong plays out
under stock audio of JFK's Moon speech
as Ryan Gosling's Armstrong contemplates
everything he's about to leave behind
it's a pretty moving trailer and it
serves as the perfect last minute hype
builder for a movie that's already
seeing an overwhelmingly positive
response from early screenings get ready
for the ride of your life when first man
touches down October 12th hunter-killer
Gary Oldman is a true chameleon one of
those actors who can transition
seamlessly from an oscar-winning
portrayal of Winston Churchill to being
the voice of a house in a silly Netflix
movie the walls are treated with a layer
of smart paint reinforced with
nanomaterials huh the walls are treated
with a layer of smart paint reinforced
when a note on it
what will he bring to Lionsgate
submarine action thriller Hunter Killer
only God knows the plot of the movie
follows Gerard Butler's captain glass a
submarine commander who's on a mission
to rescue the President of Russia how
many bad guys are they going to have to
fight through to get him back gary
oldman knows the trailer is heavy on the
torpedoes and light on anything else but
hunter-killer looks like a fun
action-packed blockbuster take a look on
October 26th the girl in the spider's
web each new trailer for the girl and
spider's web unravels that web a little
more offering up new plot details and
tantalizing glimpses of the action to
come the film is an adaptation of the
fourth book in the Millennium series
which sees Lisbeth Salander on the run
from the NSA after hacking into their
servers she'll have to team up with her
old buddy Mikael Blomkvist to sort out a
brand new conspiracy the trailer also
reveals that cylinder will have a run-in
with her estranged sister expect plenty
of snow leather and hacking when the
girl in the spider's web spins into
theaters on November 9th
The Ballad of Buster Scruggs when it was
first announced the Ballad of Buster
Scruggs was supposed to be the first TV
series written and developed by the Coen
Brothers it's since been changed to an
anthology film but the underlying
premise remains the same
it's an offbeat comedy Western that was
pieced together over the past 25 years
from scraps of stories that the brothers
just had no idea what else to do with
that may sound a little absurd but if
anyone can pull it off it's Joel and
Ethan Coen the duo behind similarly
absurd cult classics such as oh brother
were out thou and raising Arizona
look for The Ballad of Buster Scruggs on
Netflix and in select theaters on
November 16th fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald and the crimes of
grin DeVault newt scamander is back on a
brand new quest at the behest of Albus
Dumbledore the villainous grin DeVault
has magically escaped from magic prison
and Dumbledore needs new to bring him
back in with magic Johnny Depp stars as
Grindelwald who's using his free time to
recruit an army of followers to help him
rule the world
great Gellert the stakes have never been
higher and you can watch it all unfold
when fantastic peace the crimes of
Grindelwald operates in two theaters on
November 16th Creed to the rocky
franchise has always been less about
boxing and more about breaking the
audience's heart in between slick
training montages and it looks like
we're going to get a double dose of both
with creed 2 this time Adonis will be
squaring off against Victor Drago the
son of Ivan Drago who killed Apollo
Creed in rocky for now the next
generation of fans get to watch the next
generation of big screen boxers Duke it
out for the heavyweight title Michael B
Jordan Tessa Thompson and all Sly
Stallone are returning to their roles
from the first creed with a special
appearance by Dolph Lundgren as the
Siberian bull himself Ivan Drago
step into the ring on November 21st Mary
Poppins returns the original Mary
Poppins is a childhood classic a magical
romp through the imagination led by
Julie Andrews 28 teens Mary Poppins
returns won't be a remake but a direct
sequel to the 1964 original a new
tragedy summons Mary Poppins back into
the lives of the banks kids from the
original who are now adults they'll all
set off on a new and
venture that teaches these grumpy
grownups that getting older doesn't
necessarily mean you have to lose your
sense of childhood wonder Ben Whishaw
and Emily Mortimer played the adult
Michael and Jane Banks and ageless Mary
Poppins will be played by Emily Blunt
look Fred on December 19th just in time
for Christmas
Holmes and Watson after months of
hearing about the upcoming will ferrell
and john c reilly team up comedy Holmes
and Watson
expectations were pretty high this was
supposed to be stepbrothers but with
mysteries instead of all that the
trailer for Holmes and Watson just gives
us two and a half minutes of vaguely
comedic stuff to be fair this is just
the trailer it could get better comedies
are particularly hard to market so
there's still hope for Holmes and Watson
to turn out to be legitimately funny and
will be able to finally solve this
mystery when Holmes and Watson hits
theaters on December 21st bumblebee cars
and trucks are cool sure but do you know
what's cooler cars and trucks with
feelings as the Transformers franchise's
first prequel bumblebee is shifting
gears for more down-to-earth experience
that looks like a far cry from the city
smashing extravaganza is offered by the
main run of Transformers films you know
stuff like this
in the newest trailer bumblebee deepens
his emotional bond with young Charlie as
they're both caught up in a war that's
beyond their control
it's like Herbie reloaded if Herbie was
reloaded with actual bullets look for
bumblebee in theatres on December 21st
Dark Phoenix 20th Century Fox has gone
down the dark phoenix road once before
and it turned out to be a very dark road
indeed 2006 his x-men The Last Stand
marked a notoriously troubled end to the
original x-men cinematic trilogy and it
made a mess of one of the most beloved
character arcs in x-men comics history
the Dark Phoenix saga based on the
trailer for Dark Phoenix
it looks like the story may finally get
the live-action adaptation it deserves
throughout the trailer we see Gene's
slowly turning to the dark side after
absorbing the Phoenix force during a
freak solar flare accident in space it
seems to hit all the right notes and you
can look for Dark Phoenix to hit
theaters on June 7th 2019 captive state
from Rupert Wyatt director of Rise of
the Planet of the Apes captive state is
an upcoming sci-fi thriller about a
world that's been occupied by an
extraterrestrial force in exchange for
peace and prosperity for all mankind
the aliens only want one thing total
domination
those darn aliens peace among worlds the
teaser trailer for captive states shows
a ton of promise focusing mainly on the
film's hellish dystopian imagery while a
voice-over repeats the words give thanks
moon lights Ashton Sanders stars
alongside John Goodman and Vera Farmiga
and captive state is slated for a March
2019 release Captain Marvel ever since
that end credits scene of Avengers
infinity war fans have been clamoring
for more glimpses of brie Larson as
Captain Marvel now we finally got our
wish in the form of a full-length
trailer was the weight worth it
yeah kind of brie Larson does plenty of
Captain Marvel II things in the trailer
like jumping around and being powerful
what else happens glad you asked
first she crashed lands in a Blockbuster
video store because this movie takes
place in the
distant part of the past known is the
1990s even Captain Marvel can't figure
out what that place is she's so out of
touch with the world that she punches
someone's grandma but you think she was
Carroll a scroll this trailer does build
a lot of expectations for the movie and
we honestly can't wait to see it when
Captain Marvel hits theaters in March
2019